The one piece manga just kicked off the first
MAJOR battle of the final saga with Luffy
fighting a marine admiral for the FIRST TIME
in over FIVE.
HUNDRED.
CHAPTERS!
On top of that this secret agent has betrayed
the straw hats once again and is trying to
kill the genius scientist Dr. Vegapunk, but
he is now facing Zoro who has the chance to
prove to us just how powerful he truly is.
And all of this is leading to the MASSIVE
conclusion of this arc, which we were told
will completely shock the entire world, and
I have some ideas of what this event could
actually be.
But we of course have to kick off this review
with the epic clash between Luffy and marine
admiral Kizaru.
Because even though we barely get a glimpse
of it in this chapter, the start of this fight
confirms that Luffy will be taking on the
strongest opponent the world government is
sending to the island.
And this is a huge moment for Luffy to show
us just how far he has come since the last
time he faced marine admirals.
Because in case you’ve forgotten let’s
take a look at exactly how much Luffy has
been crushed by the admirals in the past.
First, he met admiral Aokiji and was completely
frozen to the point of nearly dying.
The next clash came during the chaos of the
Sabaody arc, where admiral Kizaru was sent
to take out the straw hats after Luffy punched
the celestial dragon.
And although he never directly clashed with
Luffy, the light-man was super close to taking
out the entire straw hat crew.
But then we reached the legendary war at marineford,
where Kizaru took an active role to stop Luffy
from freeing Ace.
In fact, he shot Luffy with a laser beam,
sent him flying with a light speed kick twice,
and then sniped the key to Ace’s handcuffs
right out of Luffy’s hands.
But that’s not even the worst an admiral
has done to Luffy because at the end of the
war admiral Akainu killed his brother Ace,
which ABSOLUTELY BROKE Luffy.
So yeah, Luffy has A HUGE score to settle
with these marine admirals.
Which makes this fight even more interesting.
Because on top of the actual battle to save
the Vegapunks and escape from the island,
there are both personal and world-altering
stakes at play.
So let’s actually go through all the scenarios
of what could happen based on the outcome
of this fight.
First off, no matter what I don’t think
this will be an easy fight.
Kizaru is one of the OG admirals and his devil
fruit is INSANELY POWERFUL.
Plus he is sure to show off haki abilities
that he has never shown before.
But Luffy now has awakened his devil fruit
plus learned advanced forms of haki.
And honestly, after defeating Kaido I think
that Luffy should be able to defeat Kizaru.
Personally, I’ve always powerscaled the
Yonko a bit higher than the admirals, so since
Luffy defeated Kaido then theoretically that
should make him stronger than Kizaru.
And if this were to happen, it would certainly
be a huge blow to the World Government as
it would be the first time an admiral was
actually defeated by a pirate in the story.
And no I’m not including the fight with
Greenbull at the end of Wano, which never
really got finished.
So this outcome would make Luffy’s reputation
skyrocket even more and significantly weaken
the overall threat of the marines.
However, as we all know, fights in One Piece
are HEAVILY dependent on matchups.
So just because one character should be stronger
than the other doesn’t mean they will win.
Though honestly, Kizaru’s fighting style
and devil fruit abilities don’t seem like
the type that would give Luffy trouble.
It’s nothing crazy tricky or confusing such
as the slow beams that nearly caused Luffy
to lose in Long Ring Long Land.
Essentially Kizaru fights by shooting light
beams, making a light sword, or attacking
with light speed kicks and punches.
All of these are extraordinarily powerful,
but pretty straight forward attacks.
And especially with Luffy’s awakening, I’m
wondering if he will be able to grab the light
attacks and throw them back, similar to how
he caught the lightning during Wano.
Plus since he can now make the environment
rubber, he should be able to bounce any light
beams back pretty easily.
So all this means Luffy could be defeating
Kizaru by the end of the arc.
However, I personally think the most likely
outcome here will be a draw.
It is classic Oda style to show us a clash
of two powerful characters and then something
happens to disrupt the fight.
So since Luffy’s main goal here is just
to escape with his crew and new friends, I
could easily see the fight with Kizaru ending
early and then the straw hats escaping off
the island.
Plus I don’t think Kizaru has the personality
to hunt them down, as long as he can complete
his mission of retrieving the Vegapunk tech,
which we’ll talk more about in just a minute.
But if we are considering a Luffy win and
a draw, then we also must think about what
would happen if Kizaru wins this fight.
Because we have actually never seen Kizaru
go all out in a fight, so he may have been
holding back all this time.
And maybe he overwhelms Luffy with his speed
and power, and if this were to happen it would
be devastating for Luffy and the crew.
They might not be able to escape or at least
if Luffy is taken out then Kizaru might go
crazy attacking the rest of the crew.
And oh my god, that could lead to a seriously
bad situation for the group.
I could even see someone dying in this scenario,
possibly a Vegapunk or even one of the straw
hats.
And if this were to happen it would definitely
mean Luffy needs more power ups in the future,
since he will eventually have to fight to
take down the World Government.
And you might be thinking those are all the
options but there is actually one more possibility
for this fight that we haven’t discussed.
Which is that with all of the crazy technology
here on Egghead Island someone besides Luffy
may end up fighting against Kizaru.
And in case you forgot we were actually shown
THE PERFECT WEAPONS to fight against the light
fruit user at the start of the arc, when this
version of Vegapunk showed off these awesome
gloves that let anyone physically attack light
by punching a hologram.
I mean what better way for someone without
haki to fight against the Light devil fruit
user?
And that's not all because Bonney also found
this ridiculous lightsaber that I would LOVE
to see actually used in a fight.
So could we see some of the other straw hats
fight Kizaru?
Or maybe even the different versions of Vegapunk
sacrificing themselves to let the straw hats
escape?
It is certainly possible, but if this is the
case then what other incredible event could
shock the entire world?
Well, there are a few options because we have
to remember the World Government’s goal
here in the first place.
They came here to kill Vegapunk, but we also
recently learned that they are after the Mother
Flame technology, which is something that
helps them fuel the super weapon that destroyed
this entire island.
But that doesn’t seem like world-shattering
news on its own because if Vegapunk was killed
the government would probably cover it up,
and the world doesn’t even know about the
Mother Flame in the first place.
So if it’s not either of those, then I really
only see two other options.
And wow, these would both seriously shake
up the world.
First, can you imagine the reaction if the
Gorosei member sent to Egghead, Saint Saturn,
was actually killed during this battle?
It would be unimaginable and likely cause
chaos in the entire world government.
I mean we know that he has some sort of powers
from the flashback chapters at the reverie,
but we don’t really know how strong he is.
So if he gets into a fight, things could go
very bad.
Or the other option involves another group
of pirates who have been mysteriously missing
from these last few chapters.
That’s because we saw just a glimpse of
a Blackbeard ship coming to Egghead, but assassinating
a member of the Gorosei is exactly the kind
of thing that they would do to cause chaos
in the world.
And I could definitely see this happening
whether Blackbeard himself is here or if it
is just two of the sneakiest members of his
crew.
Speaking of his crew, there is also the possibility
that Caterina Devon, who uses the shape-shifting
Nine-Tailed fox devil fruit, could currently
be posing as an imposter on the island.
But whether their goal is to kill the Gorosei,
steal Luffy’s poneglyph copies, or something
else, we will have to wait and find out.
But the other world-shaking event that could
happen is that all of the super secret historical
research that Vegapunk has collected could
be shared with the world.
I mean we know that Punk Records is basically
like the internet, so what if something happened
and Vegapunk pushed a magical red button that
subscribed him to this channel for more one
Piece content…
Oh and it also sends all of that super secret
data to the entire world?
This would LITERALLY be the World Government’s
worst nightmare because Vegapunk has information
about the Void Century and the Ancient Kingdom.
And if that’s not enough to shake the world,
then I don’t know what is.
However, while all of that is speculation
we do know that Lucci is now trying to kill
Vegapunk again, and Zoro has stepped up to
stop him.
Which honestly is kinda disappointing for
both characters.
I mean, Lucci got washed by Luffy so now he
has to fight the second in command, and I
personally feel like Zoro should handle Lucci
no problem since he has unlocked his advanced
conqueror’s haki.
On the other hand, Lucci is an awakened Zoan
user now, so we’ll have to see how much
of an actual fight Oda decides to make it.
But really the fight I would have LOVED TO
SEE would have been Zoro against Kizaru.
It surely would have been more of a challenge
than Lucci and would have pushed Zoro to his
ultimate limits.
And even though I desperately want to see
this fight, I don’t think Zoro would actually
win at his current level.
Which also makes me wonder how Zoro is going
to grow stronger in the future.
So maybe to help him fight the top tiers in
the story he might need a COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
powerup such as an ultra powerful devil fruit.
So if you want to see just how INSANE the
story would get if Zoro ate a devil fruit,
you can watch this video right here.
Shanks for watching and I’ll see you in
the next one.